♪♪♪
やべっ
体がだるい
そんなきつくはないんですけど
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
体がだるい、喉が痛い、鼻水が止めらない
すいません
体調が悪いです
なんでこんな嬉しそうなんだ
はいというわけでまだ微熱なんですけども
非常に身体がかったるくて間違いなく風邪でございます
はじめしゃちょーです
考えられる原因は2つ
12月が非常に忙しくて
度重なる過労と
髪の色です
ほんとちょっと2日間だけこの色だったんですけど
異常にバレるんですよ
動画見てないような人にも見られて
この色ちょっと恥ずかしくなってきたので
ちょっと今日はオナシャスちょっと
髪の毛だけ染めさせてください
お願いします
髪の毛だけ染める動画です今日は。
そもそもこの赤ともうほぼ緑だな
そもそもこの髪の毛に色が入るのかどうかという問題もあります
下手したら大失敗ですね
ごめん今日ちょっとホントにまじな方で体調が悪いので
そのご報告と髪の毛を直しますという動画でございます
この後も東京行かなきゃいけないんで
行く前になんとか髪の毛だけでも戻して
少しでも体調が良くなればと思っております
だけど12月はねイベントも含めて色んなことに頑張れたので
ま～そのツケが回ってきたというか
というわけでコチラ
黒髪もどし
もう黒でいいでしょ
この色を多分直すには黒しかないと思ったので
普通に今回は髪の毛を黒くしていきます
一回体調も落ち着きたいし髪の毛も落ち着きたいという意味で黒にしますね
*くしゃみ*
すいません今日動画休もうと思ったんですけど
いきなり次から髪の毛黒いと皆もビックリすると思うんで
髪の毛の色だけ変えさせてください
よーし染めます
髪の毛だけはなんとしてでも直す
赤はでも似合うと思ったんですけど
こっちの色がね
微妙だったね
まあでもイベントで最後こういうちょっと世間に衝撃を与えられたのが嬉しかったんですけど
やっぱ飽きちゃうよこの色は
( ^)o(^ )
わっもう暗い
そしてもう暗くなった
うぉうおぉうぇー
あれ染まらないこれ？ひょっとして
嫌な予感がしてきた
う～んどうなんだろう
洗い落としてみないとわかんないっすね
一回洗い落としてきます
では
はいというわけで無事真っ黒になりました
いいんじゃないすか？
完璧に色の違いが..んっ？？
うわああ微妙にちがうううう
全然違うやないかい
パッと見わかんないんですけど
近くだったら完全に色が違う
ううう
やばいぞこれは
鼻水
大丈夫、多分わかんないと思う
けど
やっぱりここら辺でちゃんとわかるわけよ
こっちが青で、こっちが赤
うわあああおｎん(≧Д≦)
やばいぞこれは
自然に赤と青落ちてくと思うので多分大丈夫だと思います
多少マシになった
ふ～一安心
熱も下がったっしょ
*くしゃみ*(≧Д≦)
多分ね今歯が痛いから
今、歯が痛くてご飯食べれないってのもあるし
色んなのが重なって非常に体調のコンディションが悪いです
まあちょっと冬なので皆さんも是非風邪気を付けてください
早く治します
じゃまた